les capsules concepts sont des épisodes
spéciaux réservés aux membres de ma page
patronne sur ma page patronne vous
trouverez plus d'une centaine de
publications inédites les épisodes
retour les 17 minutes les cours en visio
sans parler de mes articles et des apéro
philo
rejoignez-moi sur patriotes pour y
accéder le lien est dans la description
la morale c'est la branche de la
philosophie qui cherche à définir les
règles d'une bonne conduite
c'est à dire d'une vie conforme au bien
mais qu'est ce que le bien
tous
bien est la bonne
cette question tout le monde n'a pas la
même réponse
or certains la morale est une affaire
subjective
ou en tout cas relative
dire que nos règles morales sont
relatives c'est dire que les règles qui
distingue ce qui est légitime de ce qui
ne l'est pas
le résultat de notre culture
notre milieu
de notre époque
or notre conception du bien
qu'est ce qui fait que le meurtre est
quelque chose de mal
fait souffrir celui qui est tué
tu es sans faire souffrir
parce que l'interdît du meurtre est ce
qui permet de vivre en société
dans ce cas la morale n'est rien d'autre
qu'une loi qui ne dit pas son nom
est ce parce que la vie doit être
respectée mais alors le problème ne fait
que se déplacer
car on quoi la vie devrait-elle être
respectée
qu'on pose la question morale la
question ce qui est bien et de ce qui
est mal
rhji immanquablement une autre question
au nom de quoi
qu'est ce qui fait que le bien et le
bien
pendant des siècles la morale soutenu
par la religion
c'est à dire par la croyance en dieu
eux était le garant du bien
et était exprimée dans le texte révélée
pour faire le bien il suffisait donc
d'obéir à dieu
hardy c'était pour une raison simple
interdisait
or on ne discute pas les décrets divins
et lorsque la flore
on va commencer à décliner
lorsque selon la célèbre formule de
nietzsche dieu est mort
pas disparu pour autant
tant que le bien peut exister
indépendamment de la foi en dieu
pensez quand
et bien qu'il fût protestants
quand penser que la morale ce fondée non
pas sur la foi mais sur la raison
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'impératif
catégorique
sion de suivre le bien quelles que
soient les circonstances
obligation s'exprimer ainsi
telle sorte que tu puisse vouloir que la
maxime de ton action soit érigée en loi
universelle
oral selon kant
sion guidée par une volonté bonne
mais
définition les critiques ne se sont pas
fait attendre
on a reproché à quand son formalisme
c'est à dire le fait que son impératif
catégorique ne nous disaient toujours
rien sur la nature du bien
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
concrètement une volonté bonne
la question reste en suspens
les utilitaristes se sont élevées contre
la morale de compte on remarquez que
cette conception du bien et est non
seulement abstraite mais surtout fausses
pour jeremy bentham fondateur de
l'utilitarisme on appelle bien ce qui en
réalité
est de nature à augmenter notre bonheur
ral interdit le meurtre non pas parce
que la vie serait doté d'une valeur
particulièrement sacré
mais parce que nous avons intérêt à
interdire le meurtre
parce que tout simplement le meurtre et
un désagrément
réellement attiré par le plaisir comme
il est naturellement rebutés par la
douleur
et donc il a inscrit dans la morale
l'obligation de faire ce qui est
avantageux au bonheur et l'interdiction
de faire ce qui est source de
désagréments
car quoi de plus efficace pour éviter un
désagrément que de l'interdire
gasc que le frappé du sceau de
l'illégitimité
nietzsche art
d'arguments à son compte
oui nous appelons bien ce qui est
conforme à nos intérêts
la générosité serait-elle du côté du
bien
ico l'égoïsme serait du côté du mal
réponse
parce que c'est dans notre intérêt
parce que c'est dans mon intérêt que
l'autre soit là pour me venir en aide le
jour où j'aurai besoin de lui
autrement dit
notre intérêt vital qui guide nos lois
morales
selon nietzsche ou pas corps
du rapport concret et matériel à
l'existence
bon les lois de nos besoins corporels
qu'il ait mal que l'oiseau de proie le
mange
il dira que l'oiseau de proie et méchant
parce que tout bêtement
son intérêt d'être mangés
pour nietzsche un moral n'est donc rien
d'autre que la forme culturellement
admise de l'intérêt
ce qu'il appelle la morale d'esclaves
la morale fondée sur la culpabilisation
du fort
la morale qui consiste à dire la force
c'est mal
ce que le faible n'a pas intérêt en tant
que faible à ce que le fort exprime sa
force
et encore moins son encontre
cette conception ral cette course qui
consiste à dire que la morale est
d'abord une affaire d'intérêt c'est ce
qu'on appelle le nihilisme
autrement dit
l'idée que les valeurs morales n'ont pas
de réalité au delà de notre esprit
elles le sont pour reprendre une
terminologie moderne
construction
une construction de l'esprit qui exister
en dehors de lui ce qui n'existe qu'à
l'intérieur de lui
par définition la morale se superpose à
la réalité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la morale n'existe pas dans la nature
oral ne relève pas des faits
un crime un mensonge un vol
fait
mais dire qu'un crime le châtiment le
mensonge doit être condamné ou que le
vol est il légitime
c'est ajouter quelque chose à la réalité
s'est ajoutée à la réalité un jugement
elle n'est pas objective
elle relève du jugement
or l'origine du jugement
l'esprit
cette conception
elle n'était pas partagé par les anciens
et notamment par platon
pour platon
construction de l'esprit
émanation de la raison
une essence
autrement dit
tu es en soi
gardons à l'esprit que chez platon les
essences ont plus de réalité que ce que
nous appelons réalité
ce que nous appelons en réalité c'est la
réalité matérielle c'est la réalité
sensible
or pour platon les essences sont la
source de notre réalité sensible
et le bien c'est l'essence au delà des
essences
ce que nous appelons le mal
rien d'autre que la dégradation du bien
originel
dégradation c'est à dire la corruption
du bien
le mal c'est le bien qui s'est perdu en
chemin
vous connaissez la socrates
al volontairement
nul ne fait le mal volontairement ça
veut dire que tout homme croit faire le
bien
et donc que le mal n'est rien d'autre
qu'une erreur de jugement sur le bien
véritable
elle n'est rien d'autre
non
l accident lié au fait que le monde de
la matière et le monde de l'imperfection
que le monde de la matière
soumis à la loi de la dégradation
et que le bien- échappe pas à ce
principe de dégradation
prendre une analogie
l'enfant est d'abord un être pur n être
innocent
dire comme rousseau et au contact du
monde il apprend la corruption il
apprend le mal c'est à dire il apprend à
s'écarter du bien
l'apprentissage du mal
en tissage du détournement vis-à-vis du
bien
c'est ce qui faisait dire à bakounine
que satan est l inventeur de la liberté
car la liberté c'est la possibilité de
s'écarter du bien
il n'ya de mal que pour autant qu'il y a
éloignement vis-à-vis de notre tendance
originel
et notre tendance originel selon
rousseau et selon platon c'est le bien
alors c'est une vision que ne partageait
pas du tout le marquis de sade comme
vous le savez
qui considère au contraire que le mal
n'était pas moins légitime que le bien
autrement dit que toute hiérarchie de
valeurs était contraire à la nature
profonde de l'homme et du monde
pour saad
hal est un bien
elle participe de la nature au même
titre que le bien
mais si le mal n'est pas un mal si le
bien n'est qu'une invention des hommes
pour justifier la défense de leurs
intérêts
le problème de l'expérience moral
autrement dit l'expérience de la bonne
conscience et de la mauvaise conscience
c'est le problème rencontré par
raskolnikov le personnage de crime et
châtiment
qui voulant surpasser la dualité moral
voulant s'affranchir du bien et du mal
commet un meurtre
avant de se rendre compte
morale existe
elle existe dans
elle existe dans le sentiment de
culpabilité qui désormais le ronge
et qui vient lui signifier que si on
s'abstraire de la morale par la pensée
r que de s'en abstraire par les actes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]